so my final guess is this uh afternoon
and
the last interview with the tournament
magnus carlsen another very nice
win you seem to be getting fond of
extreme exchange sacrifices and
and zugswang positions yeah it's kind of
funny that
it ended up with uh with the exact same
themes as
yesterday uh well first of all huge
congratulations to duda for
winning the the world cup i mean
considering the the line of opponents he
beat in the last uh
uh for four rounds never losing a game
and obviously then never been being in a
must win or a desperate situation
um it's a massive achievement so
it's a richly deserved winner um
yeah i think um i i was
thinking a little bit actually on on the
second move today
yes yesterday i spent uh close to 20
minutes on the third and today i spent
like six minutes on the second
i was gonna ask you about that no five
minutes to decide your second move
yeah so so what was happening is that um
i uh i was
he plays everything so it's hard to
prepare for so i was just deciding
whether
we should play uh try and play uh
i should play a quiet game or just
go for a position where we play for
three results and finally i decided
that i played enough sort of
um quite games in this
uh tournament when i was up one note so
i thought
let's just let's just play and and we'll
see
fortunately it went went quite well
i think i probably played inaccurately
at some point and
let him back in the game a little bit um
but i think i was
was always was always better uh
and it's yeah it's kind of funny that
the exchange stack happened on the same
square so f5 and then f4
uh yesterday and sort of the same bishop
but
um the theme here was that once i i give
up this exchange i
i just gained control over all the key
squares um
so even though it probably doesn't have
to collapse immediately
it should be should be uh should be
winning
uh and yeah at the end i was just very
happy
to find this idea with uh bishop g4
caging in the rook so i didn't even have
to calculate any lines
so tournament finished i think these
last two wins gives you even a plus
score on your rating
has this been a good preparation for the
for the upcoming match against
nepogniacci
yeah i mean this is the first time i've
won rating and
i think since um since
summer of 2019 probably since then i was
um winning rating in every tournament
and i
gained my i equaled my highest rating
ever uh and i think
yeah i don't think i've gained ratings
since so um
obviously 11 from 14 is is a great score
um something i'm very happy with um
and i think also third place here
is something that on average i should be
satisfied with um when you reach the
semifinals
obviously you wanna you wanna win um
but winning seven matches in a row
against staff opposition is
not something you can do um on
on demand and um yeah another time
i would probably have uh have managed i
think
my the situation i was in in the
semifinals was that i had
probably considerably more than 50
chance of winning the tournament but
you don't always succeed and this time
um
i think i lost to to somebody who
deserved to
to win but yeah anyway um
i've gotten to to a point where i don't
i don't think it's like win robust every
time and
especially in in such a format i don't
think you can have that
sort of mentality and and thus i'm i'm
very
very happy with the both the results and
as you've mentioned
the practice that i've i've gotten uh
that i
that i really needed um and
i mean the chance to win some some games
i won eight games here and
um generally i've struggled to win the
last tournaments that i've played so
that i'm very happy my final question
before the upcoming match you've got
another tournament prepared
in norway maybe yeah i'm playing i'm
playing norwich s
um against amongst others
napolesi and that starts
in i think about exactly a month
so i will have some time to to rest
before that i'm also playing
um i think a couple of more champion
chess tour
tournaments and some some training as
well so
um there will be yeah there will be
plenty of chess coming up okay
thanks
[Music]